توقع الاتحاد العالمي للسمنه ان واحدا
وخمسين في المئه من سكان العالم اي ما
يتجاوز اربعه مليارات نسمه سيعانون من
السمنه او زياده الوزن خلال الاثني عشر
عاما المقبله افاد تقرير المنظمه بان
السمنه في الاطفال قد تتجاوز ضعفي مستويات
2020 سيكون الاولاد اكثر سمنه لتصل الى
ملايين
مليون فتاه بحلول عام
2035 اما بالنسبه لتكلفه علاجات الامراض
الناتجه عن ذلك ستتجاوز اربعه تريليونات
دولار سنويا بحلول 2035 اي ما يعادل 3% من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي العالمي وفي عام
2020 تم تصنيف مليارين و600 مليون شخص اي
38% من سكان العالم ضمن فئتين زياده الوزن
والسمنه وفقا لارشادات منظمه الصحه
العالميه اذا زاد مؤشر كتله الجسم على 25
فانه يعني زياده الوزن واذا زاد على 30
يعني سمنه